We are given the number 35, which is 3 decades,
because we have 3 in the order of the decimal,
that is, we have 3 tens
and we also have 5 in the order of units.
Here is the order of the units.
I will color the units in the same color - purple.
This is the order of the units.
We see that the number of units is 5,
i.e. 5 units.
Therefore, 35 is the same as
3 tenths and 5 units.
In this video we'll get the number 8 out of 35
and I encourage you to stop the video
try to find out how much it is 35 minus 8.
Let's now think together.
We have 5 units and we want to get 8 units out of them.
We do not know how to draw 8, if we only have 5.
We can get 5, but the units will end.
So how do we get 8?
That is why transporting us is very useful,
because the squares are not only 5.
Actually, we have 35 squares.
We have 3 groups of 10 squares
and another 5 squares.
What if we take one of these groups at 10,
here, here,
and we bring it here to the units?
Let's take this group here,
if we take this group of 10 squares
and instead of displaying it in the tenths,
put it to the units.
Transfer her here
in units, it will be ...,
and so one tenth will be the same as 10 units,
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6,
7, 8, 9 and 10.
What happened now?
I took one of those ten,
so now I have only 2 tens,
I took these 10 and transferred them to the units.
So I have the initial 5 units
and I have 10 more new ones,
which I took from the order of the dozen.
Therefore, 5 plus 10 equals 15.
So now I have 15 units.
And now I can get 8.
So if I get 8 now,
I will scratch 1, 2, 3, 4
5, 6, 7, 8 to make it clear.
I scratch 8.
How long will I stay?
I'll have two decades left,
there will be 2 tens
and how many units?
I have 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7 units.
7 units here.
But how to calculate this
without drawing all these squares?
If you say, "Okay, I have
3 tens and 5 units "- that's where we started.
But I took 1 of these tenes,
I took 1 of these tenes and left only 2 now,
I took that tenth and carried it to the units,
that is, I presented it as 10 units.
So 5 units plus the other 10 units
gives us 15 units.
15 units.
You can say, "15 units minus 8 units is equal to 7 units."
We see here 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7,
that is, after subtraction we have 7 units
and two more decades remaining in the order of the dozen.
We received 2 tens and 7 units. 27.